the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok welcome back everyone and me too so
what I just came back from Boulder where
I gave let's see eight talks I was on
seven panels and gave one separate talk
most on education and one of the talks
who was on teaching how to think or what
to think so there was three panelists
one professor from Berkeley in the
Astronomy Department he was also a
renowned teacher and then an
investigative journalist and then I
spoke and we all said something for
about 10 minutes I talked about the
history of Education and why it's
difficult to change educational
institutions and educational practices
and what the original purposes of the
schools were so some of this material
that I'll talk about when I in the
second to last lecture on political
barriers to educational change and I
then also just before this whole session
I described to the reporter for the
daily camera which is the paper and
Boulder a bit about what I was going to
say and I talked about some of the
material I've told you already about
multiplication table so if you remember
the multiplication table when people get
brain damage in the arithmetic area may
can't do addition anymore but they can
still do the multiplication table and
when people get brain damage in the
language area they can still do addition
but they can't do multiplication anymore
and that's because multiplication
generally is learnt as
so when you see it you think of symbols
and math but actually the way most
people learn it is 6 times 9 is 54 then
you have to learn you have to memorize
yet another fact 9 times 6 is 54 oh and
then you have to learn yet a new fact
called that these two facts are related
when actually if you understood the
meaning there would be just one fact so
now you have to memorize all these
linguistic sentences and no surprise
when you get damaged in the linguistic
area the muck that kind of
multiplication table goes away so I said
to the reporter yeah what we really need
to do is teach multiplication and math
in a whole different way so the
reporters you know she understood
everything and said oh that's really
interesting I'm actually studying
education myself and you know I have
children and I'll try to apply that with
my children and then the teaching that I
do I said oh great so then I gave my
talk and then the moderator asked
everybody well does anyone on the panel
want to say anything to anybody else and
so Alex Filippenko from Berkeley he
started we said well I agreed with you
no I agreed with everything that Sandra
said except he was quoted in the paper
this morning as saying we shouldn't
teach the multiplication table so that
whole discussion which every seemed to
be completely understood I just got
condensed into one sentence so now I
didn't actually have to say very much in
response because the second panelist as
I mentioned was investigative journalist
and when she was talking about was how
you have to be very skeptical of what's
in the media so all I could do is look
at her for a bit and then everybody
started laughing because the point was
clear but then I explained to everybody
else would I'd explain to the reporter
so that's by way of saying that
education is a complicated subject but
the audience understands a lot more than
the media does which is one of the
barriers to political change is that
there's people who understand lots of
individual points but how do you
assemble it into a coherent plan for a
change well you need forums for
discussion and if the reports and
Media ro don't teach the multiplication
table or do teach it but do it with lots
of drill well it's hard to get in a
discussion of well actually you'd like
to teach them in a different way where
instead of memorizing this you say well
60 times like 6 times 10 which is 60
minus 6 which is 54 so there's no space
for putting things like that into public
discussion one of the purposes of
classes is like like this is to do that
ok so today we're going to talk about
lecture planning and performing what
we've done so far is sort of the flow of
the ideas in this class is done as
follows so this is the logical flow we
did it slightly out of order because
it's the preparation flow slightly
different than the logical flow so you
work out your course goals or your even
your curriculum goals and then you
decide how are you going to tell whether
you've reached those goals so we just
write the golden rule clear with
problems test that's the way you
operationalize your goals and then given
that you have those kind of problems
well now you have a pretty concrete idea
of what it is you're trying for because
you have concrete examples of it well
lectures recitations so I'll put
etcetera here what do you do with your
contact time so this is what do you do
this is the overall structure this is
sort at the level where it makes
concrete sense and this is what do you
do when the rubber hits the road what do
you do in lecture so last time what we
did is we talked about interactive
teaching and there was basically several
time scales over which you could make
the class interactive the longest time
scale was the wood block the example and
I'll answer a question about that in
just a moment so now continuing the
theme of where the rubber hits the road
today so now how now that you've have
some techniques how do you set assemble
it into a lecture and I use both words
advisedly and deliberately so plan
that's an essential to plan and
performance is essential people forget
that they forget that lecturing and
teaching is a public act and when they
forget that the lectures are flat so
we're going to talk about the techniques
for doing that starting with the Walter
Lewin lecture that you watched for today
because he actually has many many
examples I think mostly good of
performance and some that I think you
could improve on then we'll discuss that
and work out and induce general
principles that you can use okay so
those are the questions from last time
it was a slight review of interactive
teaching as well and things like this
now the question is what do you do in
lecture how do you plan and how do you
perform and a good way to start
discussing that was actually if you look
at a master of the art and see what they
do now no master is perfect but I think
Walter Lewin did so many things well
it's really worth understanding what he
did and looking at it so what did you
notice from your homework problem
basically what did you notice that he
did then your honor I have a bunch of
things as well and we'll just write them
down because what we'll do I
before we've done this several times now
by looking at examples we can induce
general principles actually I'll leave
this here and I'll erase these guys
so while I'm erasing just pull out your
homework and the things you've noted
down and actually take a minute and
check with you check in with your
neighbor and see if your lists overlap
and you know sort of vet your list with
each other and see if you didn't think
about anything that could be improved
see if you can remember anything that
you would have done differently so let's
let's share all the points so I can see
that you've come up with a lot of
examples and I actually add a bunch too
so because it's such a rich lecture so
let's see what things that were done and
what was but either that you would keep
or you would change and I'll put them in
one of the other side according to how
you categorize if any one example no
indeed
okay so he tells students look this is
harder or not intuitive so he gives them
a gauge and tells him look you don't
have to worry about it before he says
something so he he he gives the
difficulty of something okay so what why
is that helpful what does that do for
students yeah
right so it gives them right so it
differentiates the lecture so I'll put
in other colors so the reasons yeah so
it gives some kind of differentiation to
the lecture it gives a structure to it
it gives you a way of evaluating so you
know what are you supposed to be doing
here and trying to learn from it you
know all of a sudden trigger your reflex
fear so it minimizes here and it gives
clear expectation so in the particular
lecture you didn't say anything was you
know you actually have to know this so
they're more than the exact flip example
but if it'd been a flip example it would
be it would have the same benefit so if
you said oh you know this is really
fundamental you really really really
really need to know this well that also
punctuates the lecture so minimizes fear
and gives it sets expectations so think
about the difference between two so to
expand on this point which is really
fundamental think about the difference
between the way a novice perceives
something and the way an expert
perceives something so a novice if you
want to know how a novice perceives
something try to remember from the days
when you were not a chess grandmaster
that shouldn't be too hard for most of
us certainly not hard for me you look at
a chess board all the moves look kind of
similar right you don't know where I
could move that pawn you think about
that for a bid you analyze some moves
he takes I take he takes I take you know
Kate let me think about when I could
move the rook I could castle he takes I
take or I'll move the bishop and you
started to say okay I'll move the bishop
right so that's how the novice or medium
chess player thinks speaking for
personal experience the way they master
the Grandmaster looks at the chessboard
the chessboard has meaning all the
different pieces of it are kind of
talking to each other well that those PI
pawn structure is really full of holes
you really want to do something about
that so the undifferentiated mass of
pieces that you that the novice sees is
completely different from what the
expert sees which is why the expert can
remember the chessboard and the novice
can't so you'll find that this I noticed
this exact
thing happened in my freshman year I
learned to play bridge so I never played
bridge before and all my friends oh I
don't know if they did me a favor or not
taught me to play bridge so I could play
bridge with them so when I first was
playing with them they would say at the
end of the hand everyone does the
post-mortem you know or your four people
you play all the tricks and everyone
talks about what happened and didn't
happen and they would say oh yeah that
why don't you play the Queen then I mean
I was like queen of what what Queen did
I have a queen you know I didn't even
remember the cards I had I didn't
remember how many cards I had of each
thing I just sort of remembered the last
card maybe or more like Oh whew the
hands over okay I can't make any more
mistakes all right so that's how I would
see it compared to how they would see it
I was like how could they ever even
remember who had the Queen of what and
you know by the end of I don't know six
months I would say uh why didn't you
play the five then you know because all
of a sudden now I was doing exactly the
same thing the hands had meaning the
cards had meaning so by doing this what
well what by giving clues to the
difficulty or ease of things you're
actually giving meaning you're
transferring some of that knowledge that
you have as the expert to the student
who otherwise wouldn't know there was
another example of that in the lecture
where he said this is the most important
equation in all of physics so similarly
he wrote that and he boxed it and he
said that's probably the most important
equation in all of physics so again he's
giving something that the expert knows
because the expert knows oh yeah when
you see this you know you're home free
and you know you can model so many
physical systems with this let's tell
the students how important it is so they
have some way of thinking about it okay
so that's that's really fundamental
others other points yes sir
uses big ideas and furnace
okay so he uses here terms for Big Ideas
many uses the same term each time so
he's careful to do that so you don't
wonder why I changed so how does that
help students
to give things names and repeatable
names yeah yeah it helps it gives a
structure to everything right it starts
to well it's gone now but it gives a
structure repeatable abstractions that
you can reuse over and over again so it
structures so in fact it's another
example of this it structures the
knowledge so it's structured in his mind
he's the expert he has a really good
sound structure flexible structure and
part of the job of really good teaching
is to help the students build that
structure yes
okay so he emphasizes the why of the
equation so why would it why is it
plausible that it for example has can
you give an example of that okay so yeah
there was an example where he's the
frequency was derived so emphasizes the
physical meaning and interpretation and
interpretation so the example you gave
which I think it's a good one is that
the mass why is the mass in a pendulum
why is the mass why is the period
independent of the mass so for a
pendulum okay and the argument for that
was oh well if you double the mass you
double the force but you double the mass
so you haven't changed the acceleration
so everything stays the same and he
contrasted that right he contrasted what
he also he didn't just do this one he
contrasted that with what happens in a
spring okay so how does this help the
students what's the benefit
okay so right so he's modeling actually
what you would do you could see you
yourself as a physicist and hopefully as
a student you want to be able to check
your answer by making sense of it so
this promotes it promotes sense making
there's a shorthand for it let me just
rush the other board up oh sorry
right
okay so teaches teaches how to think
because it's a transferable skill I mean
you may never have to analyze the
pendulum again as a student I mean
outside of the class but whatever
formula you get you can use that same
method to say does the formula make
sense so that's a teaching a way of
thinking right it's a transferable skill
yeah matrices okay split said about
notation can you give an example what
right he'll write everything out so he's
very explicit about notation so how does
that help the students what does that do
for them yes
it makes it right it makes it hard to
make mistakes so again you so it's so
this is hard to make mistakes okay and
why what what makes it harder well and
why is this so important because as
Adrienne said ya may be intuitively
obvious to the expert physicist that of
course L is the length that's why you
chose L this length begins with L but
for the student everything is new just
so think the chess example the knocking
down the chess board problem and seeing
how well you can reconstruct it
explained so much so the novice they
can't reconstruct the chessboard that's
because each piece on the chessboard is
not intuitively obvious whereas for the
chess master it's so easy to reconstruct
the board because to them it is
intuitively obvious that of course you
have three pawns in front of your King
unless you have some really crazy
opening of course you've cast on your
king and your three pawns sitting in
front of it protecting it and it's it's
just an obvious from their configuration
of the pawns that of course with that
pawn configuration you did this opening
and of course the part of the King is
defended in this way so what's obvious
to the expert is completely obscure to
the non expert so you want to make sure
that you don't you you want them to not
have to worry and fill up their
short-term memory slots with things that
really are obvious so you put that right
on the diagram so he wrote em I think
and then there was an L there so right
away you just look at the diagram you
know what L is other things that were
done there's so many
okay so he asked for help so that
increased participation yes so how did
he ask for help what did there were some
examples of that right the final
pendulum right II several times actually
he said so I think I have it here Lewin
says I want to hear you loud right
because he didn't hear those he wanted
people's apart really participate and
then they really started counting and so
they were really involved in what's
gonna happen by the end of ten swings
right so it involved them so it's a form
of interactive teaching she's getting
people more involved yes Deidre
okay he didn't ask them questions right
so it yeah it's good that he asked for
help and that is one way of involving
them so it made them interested but it
didn't necessarily I mean increase their
motivation to learn about the subject
but didn't necessarily actually help
them learn right then about something
right so he would change so he okay so
can anyone else think of spots where he
could have asked questions yeah
okay we didn't pause at the natural
breakpoints yeah right so one example
that I remember of that even cuz I was
also watching for that wasn't he had he
wanted to show Hookes law and he plotted
out draw an example here so he plotted
force versus extension for a bunch of
extensions and force was the weight of
those Springs and he got a bunch of
points here he drew this then he pulled
out pulled one of the springs and he
stretched the hell out of it right and
then he let go of it and came back much
longer than it started and then he drew
what happened on the graph so one thing
you could have done rather than drawing
it straight is the phone you say okay
how do we describe what happened to that
spring as I stretched it was it this
curve that curve or that curve ABC you
don't have to spend long on it just 10
seconds or even 30 seconds right but
instead he just told them which it was
so actually which was it a B or C C
right it was C and just the act of
thinking about that forces you to
connect the physics and the mathematics
once again right even the small amount
yes
all right okay so so he didn't pause the
natural brake grinds and he didn't pause
yeah thought that the smaller timescale
right so new five-second pause so the
questions are almost will rhetorical
right and this is one I would say it's
one of the dangers of being such a good
performer I say which he is he's
fantastic I think and one of the things
he does so well in his performance is
connecting what you mentioned over here
is connecting the physics and the
mathematics you know explaining the
physical meaning and interpretation that
top item so he does that so well but one
of the dangers of being such a good
performer is that you just steamroll or
over the students and you become in some
ways more important than the students
yeah so the five-second pause I mean you
would have you be able to do less in
lecture but the five-second pause is
really important to have everyone
tracking and falling with you other
items I don't see someone I've yet
that
why yeah okay so that when he said
things were not intuitive sometimes
didn't explain why I was not intuitive
so the one I'm thinking of is he said no
matter what the amplitude is the period
is the same and he said it isn't
intuitive so that was good in that he he
did tell people where was that
yeah that's here he gives a difficulty
he says for example this isn't intuitive
you should be surprised that the period
is independent of the amplitude but it
doesn't tell them why give them another
way of seeing why it should be they do
the derivation and you find that it is
independent of the amplitude but why so
okay so and you can explain that sort of
intuitively
just by saying if the well yes I'll give
you a quick explanation of that so it is
actually an amazing fact
so this I'll give you a quick
explanation of the unintuitive fact that
the period is independent of the
amplitude okay so this is a scaling
argument okay so let's estimate how long
it takes a mass to move a distance a
well it has some acceleration a small a
so this is the amplitude and that's the
period so the mass of some acceleration
little a and in some time T the period
or some fraction of the period let's say
Clarke quarter of the period it goes
this distance give or take factors of
two and whatnot so this is roughly the
amplitude okay now we want to figure out
what is this a here well a is the force
you can force over the mass and the
force the typical force that's coming
from the spring so it's a spring
constant times the extension typical
extension is the amplitude
okay so k times a is your force divided
by m and put that in there oh look at
that hmm and in fact there you have T is
proportional to square root of M over K
so you've got not only that the it's
independent of the amplitude but except
for the 2pi you got the feet you got the
whole story but except for the 2pi so
intuitively what it's saying is that ya
if you move yourself farther out you
have farther to go but you're pulled
harder by just enough to make the time
the same and so it not only is it an
intuitive argument is very plausible and
Galileo extended it to the pendulum and
he thought he found a proof to show that
the pendulum is actually has a period
independent of amplitude in the pendulum
the amplitude is related to the
restoring force so he thought the period
of the pendulum was independent of the
amplitude not just for regular spring
and that proof turned out to have a
slight error in it but as Walter Lewin
pointed out that that's only true at
large angles and at small angles you
can't tell the difference so you can
actually explain these non-intuitive
pieces in short ways that don't require
doing this whole calculation and that is
important to do I think okay so why
don't we take a 10-minute break and then
we'll have a quick comment yeah go ahead
yeah
okay okay so yeah so answer the who
cares question right and that's a good
point so you know I teach physics myself
so actually that one slipped me because
this is again the expert blind spot so
he said he put that equation there and I
was so glad he said most important
equation in physics and I to myself I
thought yeah right on it's you know you
use it in electromagnetism the whole
theory of quantum electrodynamics
depends on it use it in modeling
materials it's everywhere so all those
thoughts went through my mind right away
and I thought wow that's equivalent to
him saying it right but actually it's
not because the students of course have
none of those thoughts and you really do
need to say all that so ok so we'll
continue after our 10-minute break and
then we'll induce our lessons for
lecture planning and performance and
I'll give you a structure that you can
use when you plan and perform your own
lectures ok there's a several more
points to come out so we'll take some
more points about Lewin's lecture at 10
it's 10:05 by that clock so 10:15 by
that clock and if you didn't get a
comment she just grabbed one on your way
in or on your way out then I'll be here
if people have any questions during the
break
so a few other points so let me give you
one point from Lewin that I noticed and
take some more points from you to one I
thought it was very interesting and
which is not normally done in most
physics lectures on Springs so the way
it's normally done in the physics class
you would do simple harmonic motion
you'd study a whole bunch about the
spring and then maybe a few lectures
later you might get to the pendulum but
Lewin actually did both in the same
lecture which I thought was very
interesting and a really excellent
choice
so it had eaten some negative effects
which is that there's less time to talk
about things like this and maybe it
feels like there's more pressure to not
wait five seconds so it has many subtle
pressures in the wrong direction which
maybe could be mitigated by planning but
it had a really great advantage which is
that it's this figure so if there's some
idea you want to teach and the idea you
want to teach is simple harmonic motion
we called it simmer monic oscillation
but sh m is sort of standard jargon and
most of the physics books so if you want
to teach that idea just showing it in
one example is not good enough for the
students because they can't separate the
example from the idea it's just one big
morass and they can't draw this dividing
line so you have to give them another
example but if you give them a second
spring example then it's too hard it's
too still too hard suppose you do this
and yet another spring example well the
problem is that still the overlap here
is too big so you need an example that
illustrates the core idea but it's quite
different and the pendulum falls into
that pretty well
it's different in that so here and the
order was correct to it first did the
spring because the spring really is pure
simple harmonic motion
the pendulum isn't but you have to
approximate to get it there so it shows
how you get to simple harmonic motion
because you've seen it now and so the
piece you're getting to is the common
thing between these two examples and
furthermore it's different enough that
you can see what's common and what's not
what's common is the structure of the
equation the structure of the equation
is so that's common and so you have a
really particular example here of
inducing the core idea which is if you
just did Zimbardo motion with the
example of the spring students may think
simple harmonic motion is this they
thank you whenever you have K over m you
know simple harmonic motion whenever you
don't have K over m you don't have some
harmonic motion they may think that
actually it depends on exactly what's
here but because the second example are
something completely different
the second example had
the pendulum had G over L after
approximating it you get the same
structure of the equation but a new
physical phenomena and it shares the
common feature of simple harmonic motion
so it's a really excellent way of
bringing out this idea and borrowing
most of the derivation that he did
before so for example he didn't have to
resolve this equation with with these
new parameters once he'd solved this
equation all you had to do was
substitute this into the solution and
get the new solution instantly ok yes ok
so we put that I'll try to squeeze it in
here so he modulated his pace and pitch
and his gestures were very bold right he
talked about the spray he stretched the
spring actually almost broke the spring
whenever he was describing something you
could feel him feeling it in his own
body so gestures his gestures were bold
and his pace was very and paste ok how
does that help
yeah yeah yeah it's exciting it contains
enthusiasm it punctuates
so in there are several languages I
think which have no vowels and knows no
spaces well German approximately has no
spaces it's not quite true but well that
don't have vowels or punctuation in the
old days for example there was no
punctuation people just ran all the
words one after another you didn't put a
period at the end of sentences so
without punctuation you have to work
really hard to figure out what are the
units of thought so by varying your pace
and pitch you convey enthusiasm so you
convey enthusiasm and structure so the
pieces that are more important get more
importance because that are emphasized
accordingly so an example of that in
writing so that's you actually
fundamentally important in writing I
don't know if you know the following
recipe but this is the first order term
in good clear writing let's call it not
fiction writing but expository writing
is the right word so the first order
term in punctuating writing and giving
structure to your writing is this
so a sentence starts with old
information that links to something
before it continues so it this is how
the sentence ends then whatever you put
at the end of the sentence readers
expect that to be the thing that you
want to emphasize that's the new
information there's maybe a fair amount
of new information in the sentence but
this is the new interesting information
this is what readers assume has emphasis
and in the beginning of a sentence they
look for things that connect to what has
already happened it could connect to the
last emphasized thing in the last
sentence the subject of the last
sentence the thing that was the topic or
the topic of the paragraph it somehow
links to stuff before and then you're
going to say something new about it so
if you don't use that order it gets very
confusing for readers because they
expect this to be emphasized but you're
mentally emphasizing something else and
then they have to redo their
expectations each time so punctuation
the period actually is a way of saying
here came the most important information
and if you follow that structure you'll
tap into much better how your readers
understand so if you want to know more
about that I'll put some references on
the website so that this was partly
developed by Joseph Williams that you
know linguists at the University of
Chicago and George gokhan who is a
English professor and law professor at
Duke high and he's written a really
interesting article called him and
Judith Swan it's called the science of
science writing where he gives a whole
bunch of examples of restructuring prose
along these lines and how much clearer
it becomes and he's written a several
books two books actually one on teaching
this approach to writing and one on
doing it yourself it's that textbook for
such a class so I once called the sense
of structure I forget whether that's the
teaching book worthy
textbook but I'll put both titles on the
website so I highly recommend that and
what you'll see from this is the huge
importance of punctuation and here it's
the same thing by varying the pitch by
giving period semicolons and commas in
the lecture even though you can't say
okay here's the period you don't say
that but you do it by varying your pitch
and your volume in your tone you give
structure and fundamentally important
you also convey enthusiasm yes yeah he's
yeah so he maybe does it too much in
fact he doesn't vary enough because he
started sort of like the the radio and
spinal tap right it goes to 11 you know
and it starts at 10 because it's always
loud you know the amplifier is always
loud so yeah I think he could actually
use have more dynamic range no I still
would see war in his defense oh yes go
ahead
okay so in his defense you could say
well when do you want to have be really
quiet well that's when you're doing
something that's less important and he's
actually such a good lecturer that he
planned a lecture I would say quite well
he took out all the stuff that normally
you would find in a lecture on this
that's kind of dull like for example one
thing that people do that's really kind
of dull is they may derive the sinusoid
as a solution and how did he derive the
sinusoid Shh right spray paint he said
well what they did an experiment he made
he made it visible he had a spring
oscillating up and down with spray paint
so he was spraying on a big piece of
paper and then he pulled the piece of
paper that way so as the spring
oscillate up and down and sprayed on the
sheet of paper it made a track which you
could see developing and then he just
showed the class he said what does this
look like and they said oh it looks like
a sinusoid
there you go now you've skipped a whole
bunch of painful math or otherwise which
to do to make the guess and so although
either you guess it or you do a bunch of
derivation he's he avoided both of those
problems by actually just having the
students see for themselves in fact you
use the word see I want to make you see
what it is so he got that so he's taken
out a lot of stuff where you would
normally just try to pretend you were
doing and speak really quietly now so
that's maybe one explanation for why his
dynamic range wasn't as big as it should
be right but yeah I think generally the
point is right that he he's so forceful
and loud that it would be better if he
just had a twice as much range you have
amplification yeah and he did have a
microphone because he was being taped
but you're right the habits of thought
and presentation come from when we
didn't have microphones yes
yeah yeah
that's a really good point so that the
yeah the test results discussion at the
beginning so I always knew this lecture
was a classic one and this is the first
time I watched it straight through
rather than just watching the sort of
demonstration parts in the famous part
and so it started off with this result
about to this discussion about test
results where he says all kinds of
interesting things so I you did very
well on your first exam that's word one
in the lecture I was hoping for an
average of about 75 so hoping I mean
that's not a word I would have used
right I would hope for an average of a
hundred that's my hope maybe not what I
expect but my hope is a hundred so he's
by saying hope he's saying actually
would be good if people got a lot of
stuff wrong like you know I'm hoping
that people get 25 percent wrong and
then that could be interpreted as hoping
that the students don't do great but
then on the other hand the class average
was 89 okay so that's good news now as
you say he says either you are very
smart
this is an exceptional class or the exam
was too easy and he eventually concludes
no the exam was taken by the instructor
so you guys are a smart class but even
that he takes away by saying but time
will tell whether you are indeed
exceptionally smart or whether the exam
was too easy
so even the good news is tempered and
taken partly back and then even the good
news itself as you point out correctly
is not necessarily good for helping the
students learn so there's very
interesting studies I wish I could
remember the name she's a psychology
professor at Stanford and she's done
Studies on with kids so what you do is
you ask that you have the kids do a a
problem and then you tell them either
that they worked hard at it or that they
were very smart that's why they solved
it okay so there's one you you tell the
group a that oh yeah you worked really
hard at it
that's why you solved it Group B
you saw you must be really smart and
then you see what kind of problems they
try later the group a who were told you
know I worked well let's do group B
first the who are told you did it
because you were smart they only later
this is making an extreme of it but this
is the trend they don't want to solve
hard problems because the only thing you
can get out of solving hard problem is
you don't solve it which then proves
that you're actually not as smart as
people thought so they want to solve
easy problems the group that was told oh
yeah you did that because you work
really hard they enjoy solving the
problems and then they they want to
solve hard problems that they can't
necessarily solve because they can work
on them and some of them even say things
like I love it when a problem is hard
right which is a completely different
attitude than the attitude of the people
like oh I don't want to try anything
because I might fail then then the truth
about me will come out so by making
comments about people's intrinsic
characteristics so there's a I made
distinction earlier between intrinsic
motivation and extrinsic motivation and
how you really want to use intrinsic
motivation but there's the flipped one
which is you don't want to make
intrinsic comments about people because
that's very hard to change and very
fixed then that's what people are doing
way too much of so whenever people can't
solve things it's because you didn't
work hard enough the conditions weren't
right we'd call it making excuses but it
isn't it's an optimistic way of looking
at the world and it's that optimism that
people learn when they have control over
the things that lead to problem-solving
successfully or not so yeah I thought
the opening was actually very bad in
terms of that and actually set a kind of
competitive hierarchical tone which I
would have definitely avoided other
comments the other things you noticed
yeah
right right
yeah right so uh race to this guy right
so he's first three he's shedding patch
he's losing passion right he's done I'm
sure he's done the demo many many times
for every year every semester yeah I no
doubt yet he was still so excited so for
example the ending what did he say so so
he wrote they did ten oscillations with
Walter Lewin as the pendulum Bob right
and then they counted up to ten so then
he got to ten T with Walter Lewin forty
five point six plus or minus 0.1 seconds
and the prediction was forty five point
seven plus or minus point one so it was
right on the nose said physics works I'm
telling you see you Monday right so he
he ends with enthusiasm he has
enthusiasm throughout all the way
through so it yeah it is contagious and
people did applaud it I'm sure it wasn't
just because it was being taped I mean
they really were very pleased and amazed
that the agretti close to agreement even
when he changed the pendulum bob from
just the regular pendulum bob of a few
kilograms to Walter Lewin of 70
kilograms or he's probably more but
probably eighty kilograms and throughout
as well doing the demonstrations he was
also very enthusiastic in even sometimes
he got lucky right and even said so but
he said fantastic agreement between
theory and experiment yes so the
enthusiasm it transfers and in fact our
our our system our brain is actually
much better at picking up this kind of
stuff than it is at picking up the navvy
or Stokes equations and things like that
so this it has a well let's call it an
emotional highway it was in the
emotional highway
so I mentioned the experiment that you
can do to test this the experiment you
do is you just go somewhere and you just
smile at people right and now like 30 40
50 percent of the class is smiling back
already right you can't help it
right even though you know and I'm
telling you I'm just doing this there's
nothing actually funny that just
happened right now I'm just smiling just
because I'm a nice guy and I'm smiling
and I just want to see if the experiment
works you can't help it right so that
tells you how powerful that emotional
highway is so it's not just for smiling
its they're losing passion so
neurologically neurobiologically there's
that mechanism is starting to be
understood so they knew the mechanism
I'll write the mechanism down we have
what are called mirror neurons and so
what mirror neurons do is they recreate
the state of mind of other people in us
so that's why they're called mirror
neurons and their innate it seems that
monkeys have them we have them there's
nothing you can do about them and they
are actually probably the mechanism by
which we become social creatures and
which makes those social creatures so if
people around us are unhappy we feel
unhappy the people around us are happy
we feel happy and these mirror neurons
they're firing tendencies a partly set
in young childhood so if the people
around you are happy in childhood you'll
have a much easier time just
automatically being happy later and if
the people around you and childhood are
really unhappy and you're f child was
unhappy you have to work much harder
later to overcome that so that's the
importance of childhood I and child
upbringing but now these are there and
your students all have them being people
so how you act and how you perform is
going to affect them much more strongly
than any equation you say so it's fun
it's fundamentally important again okay
any other points
yes this spray-paint can yeah
to show it okay so what's the purpose so
I so it could go here or here that the
the spray-paint example so the so the
normal way it's done is that you either
just guess it outright you say well
we've seen that equation before we being
the Royal we the instructor seen the
equation before and says use the
sinusoid the students have never seen it
before and just have to take it on faith
and so then you put in the sinusoid and
then you show that it solves the
equation the other way you do it is you
separate the equation okay you there's
many techniques for solving that
equation one is you separate it into
write it in terms of operators and
factor the operators but the freshmen
aren't really ready for that so you
can't really do that so you're basically
reduced to guessing at least in the
American curriculum so now what he's
done is he's done an improvement on that
instead of saying just by bold assertion
or just outright Authority saying please
guess this he's saying look this is what
it did what do you think it is and then
the students say oh it's a sinusoidal
okay good that justifies the guess
basically that I was gonna make anyway
so it improves on the standard method of
guessing and just plugging in but you're
right not always can you do that
so maybe were the thing I would have
done is I would have fired him I would
have said this is going to avoid us just
either guessing the solution or doing a
whole big long calculation and he does
say that elsewhere when he talks about
the zoo when he wrote down the
differential equations for the X motion
and the Y motion and he said hook that
has a coupled nonlinear equation it's
hopeless it looks like a zoo and it is a
zoom ok so then he approximated it so he
was quite good at saying look there's
some things you just don't want to do
and this would have been I think another
spot to do that he could have explained
why he was going to do the experiment
okay just one other point I think that
wasn't mentioned so far
oh yeah well it yeah he never erases
what he's using so if you noticed how
the we'll talk about that more in the
next time when we talk about using chalk
and slides if you notice he never erased
anything he needed now you could just
call that chance so an example of when
he had stuff that he was using before he
had the differential equation
and then that was way up in some board
and then later after doing experiment
with the spray-paint he came to so now
he had to calculate X and X dot the
derivative and X double dot and then put
it in well as he was doing that
fortunately this equation was still
there the whole time it was just high up
so he'd never had erased anything he
needed later and I was watching pretty
carefully through the whole lecture I
think there was no time when that had
happened and you could call that chance
maybe if it happened once it would just
be chance but it's actually preparation
right so that's part of lecture
preparation what am I going to need and
make how do I make sure that it's still
visible so that it's not or you can
write it again that's also fine but how
do I make it so that students don't have
to remember and flip back in their notes
because to them this is a new equation
it's not just doing the equivalent of
one pond one chunk it's six or seven
chunks so you don't want to fill up
their short-term memory kind of remember
that you want it visible somewhere and
that was the also planning look yes
yeah he did call tension to force I was
most upset about that and that is the
standard way it's done and all the
physics courses I took as undergraduate
did the same thing and I'm sure that's
how I got confused about it
and I'm sure most people are confused
about it because of that and until they
do a few thought experiments or have to
teach it and really sort through it they
won't figure out that it's actually not
a force now I'm sure Walter Lewin
doesn't internally think of it as a
force he knows it behaves differently
but it's so easy to use this shorthand
and then the students they don't have
any other structure for it they'll just
think it does act like a force it adds
like vectors but it doesn't yeah so that
was I thought a dubious point but its
standard unfortunately so just because
something's standard there's a good
lesson that just because something
standard doesn't mean it's a good thing
to do
yeah big yeah use right so he used big
he used so this is actually if you need
to order this chalk it's called railroad
crayon so you want to be careful to get
railroad crayon because there is
actually chalk big chalk you can buy
from I don't know like variety stores
but the problem and that's for example
writing messages on sidewalks and the
problem with that is that has wax in it
so that it stays against the rain but
that's not so good for the blackboard
it's much harder to get off so railroad
crayon is designed to be removed easily
so if you weren't a railroad crayon
unfortunately it seems to come in boxes
of 144 maybe you can get a box of 72 ISO
share it around if you find a source
with smaller amounts let me know but the
ones we found were 144 a dozen gross one
dozen dozen but yeah he used Braille or
crayons so it was very easy to see what
he was doing
and he used colors for example horses
were always red and used a consistent
naming convention for that okay so he
wasn't throwing noise onto the system
yep
so he created suspense by taking a risk
so there was there was actually tension
not this kind of tension but the the
good kind of tension where people were
involved and interested because he redid
the experiment and it could have come
out not quite right and amazingly it did
come out right and when it does then the
point he's trying to make is even more
strongly reinforced about physics works
right and that was his goal that was one
of his overall goals for the implicit I
don't know if he ever stated it but is
in one of his implicit goals you can see
is to convince people that physics works
it's a way of understanding the world
and if you really believe that well you
should really willing to put your money
where your mouth is and do it yourself
there's an another famous experiment I
don't know if it's in Lewin's lectures
but where you want to show that energy
is conserved and the way you measure
energy conservation is that the pendulum
the height how far our pendulum swings
so now the way you do the experiment you
have some giant pendulum with a bowling
ball or a cannon ball at the end hanging
from the top of the physics lecture hall
which is about this high and you release
it from your nose and you just stand
there
so if energy is really conserved it's
gonna come just where you released it
and no farther which is good because
your nose is right there a little
farther would hurt the problem happens
so this still doesn't show physics
doesn't work but it looks like it is
that it's so tempting to give it a
little push when you release it and it's
just hard not to do because you know
whenever you let go of things you know
you push a ball you throw something in
the laundry basket so now you give it a
little bit of push and physics works so
it comes back with exactly the same push
which wouldn't be a problem if it was a
wiffle ball or a tennis ball but because
it's a giant cannonball and at the other
end of its your nose that gives me a
nice crunch right there so that too I
mean I wouldn't recommend I would only
do that experiment if I'd practice it
and make sure I didn't push
but even if you do push it it too shows
physics works well but yeah he he
created suspense yes so how can you do
it in other fields yeah it's a good
question
so if you remember the wood blocks maybe
there's some sort of physics mechanical
engineering
there was also suspense right because
when I tap this this one and then
everyone was dead silent before we tap
this one just for review right because
everyone wanted to know so the suspense
was created and it's just like any sort
of magic trick or performance you have
to prepare for it you have to prepare it
so it doesn't have to be that you bring
something in all right I mean it helps
but let's see what else could you do it
in chemistry so in chemistry you can it
helps to break stuff in it no question
you could bring in chemicals what do you
think is gonna happen when I mix these
two well what do we know about this what
do we know about this what's going to
happen when I drop a ball through this
is this viscous is it not what clues did
you have okay let's see if now that's
consistent with how the thing behaves so
it doesn't have to be pure physics
though it does help to break things in
and so you do want to make everything
you have as as visceral and as
visualizable as possible
so that is a general transferable
principle so let me write down four
general principles that you can use in
all lecture performance which basically
grow out of is basically everything you
said here
so one that I'll write the first one I'm
going to write down is very neglected
but you've just mentioned it which is
the suspense and the timing so if you
want evidence that timing really matters
just go watch Romeo and Juliet again
there I read Romeo and Juliet right just
because they were slightly off in their
timing they all committed suicide
basically all right you know they were I
mean that's not probably the that's
probably very very very very cliffnotes
plot summary so and another part about
timing if you want more evidence that
timing really matters try telling a joke
and tell the punchline first see how
well that does right and even a small
example that so four stories to stories
you want to tell the important part
later and you want to give the
introduction first so in the end
remember the sentence structure here
which is that your thing with emphasis
comes right at the end so if the thing
you want to emphasize happen at the
beginning then your timing is off and
things will fall flat yes
yeah
so well so okay so that's a good comment
which is that it's opposite of how
people say they want things they want
the most important stuff first and then
the details so the way I square that
circle is I don't want to give away
punchlines so whenever I'm we do know
those are gone so suppose I'm starting a
new unit and we're gonna do a unit on
extreme cases I don't want to give away
the punchline which is oh this problem
is hard until you use extreme cases so I
say forget the organization of the
course that I told you about before and
we're just going to do an example and
discuss it and then we're going to look
at what makes it really easy and then
the punchline is extreme cases okay so
now that we know the punchline because
we've done the example now I'm very
happy to say extreme cases okay let's
use extreme cases here and this whole
unit is going to be about extreme cases
so now people still have the structure
but the very beginning of it they're a
little confused and I like the confusion
so that's part of this so in a play or
in a movie right you go to a movie and
you're not even sure who are the main
characters what are they up to and then
it comes into focus soon but not right
away and part of that is to draw you in
so yeah I don't I wouldn't begin a
lecture by telling people everything
that they need to know because that's
spoiling the timing the beginning of the
lecture is this kind of sacred moment
when you want to draw everybody in to
the lecture rather than for example and
the beginning of a course is doubly that
much you don't you want to draw people
in not tell them oh yeah here are the
rules on homework collaboration and
lolololo a lot so you want to emphasize
the important things first we want to
use this to pull people in so that you
can come to a punch line the punch line
doesn't have to be way at the end of the
lecture at the end of the course it can
be sued and you could have a lot of soon
punch lines but for each one you need to
build to it yes
yeah that's right I think what I would
do is I would show them that goals I
might leave it on the so goals are okay
as long as you don't sort of begin the
lecture by saying here are my goals
because that's the sacred time you're
taking away from I would put the goals
say on a sideboard so they can see them
all the time or right then just after
you've done your punch line then put
them all up yeah that's right yeah so
it's much more of a draw so the very
first slide is something interesting
that doesn't necessarily seem like it's
related to the class and that's already
a punch line oh wow this we can
understand this from the stuff in class
I want to know so that's the well that's
a drawing in and then you get to the
punch line which is yes you can and the
goals are to see this all over and see
these three principles that we just use
and really understand them okay so the
another one is bold be bold so bold
gestures bold gestures voice you'll see
that all throughout Walter Lewin I
another one we've actually done I would
say a lot more with it then you saw in
the lecture it is
and the third one is you want to involve
the audience by asking them questions
making your whole lecture interactive so
we've discussed actually many ways where
the Lewin lecture could be improved in
that direction and perhaps underlying
everything none of this really works
unless there's a principle for which is
that you have to care you have to really
really love what you're doing and
transmit that to the students and then
all of these things become so much
easier when you care so those are the
fundamental principles of lecture
performing and basically planning around
things like that and if I just had
written those down in the beginning and
wouldn't it made sense but now you can
you've seen many many many examples and
we've had many discussion about it that
I wish you success in applying good
timing good bold gestures strong
gestures and involving the audience so
that not just in emotionally or
cognitive both so that you provide long
lasting learning and interest in the
subject that you love okay so if you
could fill out the sheets for just one
minute and then we will have office
hours actually what we'll do is we'll
meet right outside the door and then
we'll just go sit in the cafe area and
anyone who wants to get a bagel can also
get a bagel if you're interested answers
from lecture eight to questions
generated in lecture seven
so first question was a while ago that I
mentioned there was research saying that
if you pay people for things they like
doing then they enjoy it start enjoying
it less so can can I give you a
reference for that so that the reference
for that is actually put on the readings
for next week which is the political
barriers to educational change session
one of the five readings they're all
basically short I is by alfie kohn and
it's about competition and that's one of
the areas he researches a lot so so I
gave you one of the short articles by
him to read but his whole website has
millions of different millions lots of
different articles and references his
book he has a whole book on the whole
subject called called no contest
I think the subtitle is the case against
competition so he goes through I don't
know hundred or 200 studies about the
affects of rewards on people's
performance and interest and all kinds
of it's a totally fascinating book and I
think it just came out or reason it has
a second edition but both editions are
completely fine so whichever you can
find use that in on his website you'll
find many articles on that theme and
I've given you one to read for next week
okay what is the Berkeley physics course
so the Berkeley physics course so this
is interesting because in the 60s there
was a whole bunch of change
it was change in political systems and
protests and legal systems you know the
Civil Rights Act and there was also
change in education and that's probably
not coincidence that they both changes
both changes were coupled or happened
together so there was the rise of the
free school movement there was also a
unit in the university level lots of
different new curricula started so the
Fineman lectures on physics are a famous
one that happened way way over on the
other side of the country in Caltech and
the Berkeley physics course it happened
also on the other side of the country
and the same there are several volumes
and it probably the best
known as edy / cells electricity and
magnetism so that's one of the classics
of the Berkeley physics course there's a
less well known volume which is I think
even better which is by Frank Crawford's
called waves and the addition I have
came in the back with a whole bunch of
polarizers and toys you could use to
actually do home experiments and at the
end of every chapter there are home
experiments to do I can they could call
kitchen sink experiments no and there is
toys in the back in a little pocket that
you could use for it so if you find a
used copy those toys might not be there
but the book is still wonderful so those
were two pieces of the Berkeley physics
course and they were about six volumes
and MIT had a whole set of books as well
I think by Tony French so it was a whole
time of permit and lots of changes
happen many of them good okay so how can
you apply these lecture techniques that
we talked about last time to laboratory
of practical courses so this is actually
an important topic because many of us
will do that know what's the right
balance between teaching and lecturing
and allowing students to solve the lab
problems on their own my words giving
them enough rope to hang themselves yeah
so you do want to do that you want to
give people enough rope but you also
want to guide them because that's you do
know more than them so I I don't look at
lab laboratory teaching practical
teaching is that different than lecture
teaching in some ways it's easier
because one of the goals in lecture
teaching is to show people that all the
theory you're talking about actually has
any relevance at all then you have to
try to work hard to bring stuff into the
classroom and really show yeah look this
really means something no way you know
Walter Lewin stood I stood on the
pendulum or sat on the pendulum himself
and was the pendulum really show yes
this applies here so in a laboratory
practical class if the practicals are at
all interesting you know that's
automatically done for you so the last
would see the last practical class I
taught was electronics practical for
physics majors and so that was at the
end they built an AM radio crystal radio
so that actually had a nice finale and
experiments before that built up to it
so all the relevance was already done
done for me
but the problems the students had were
the same as in regular lecture they
didn't understand the concept for
example what is what does a capacitor do
what does an inductor do how do they
work together
what is resonance so what I did for them
is I gave them short little mini
lectures you know two minutes three
minutes on a conceptual question and
then sent them off working I also
there's some of the other problems they
had were for example they were really
scared of oscilloscopes so when they
just got to the oscilloscope they
thought what the hell do I do with this
thing so that I use an exercise that was
done to me when I took the same class as
an undergraduate which was in your
laboratory pair one person turns around
and the other person randomizes the
oscilloscope settings so they just turn
all the dials to some random setting and
then the first person that's a turn back
and try to get some signal on the screen
so they have to figure out you know okay
this voltage setting is crazy and get it
back to a setting and once you do that
you're no longer afraid of your Solus
cope so again there you can do in class
problems that people work on together
you can give short little conceptual
questions so in wake laboratory teaching
isn't that different provided that the
laboratory isn't just a cookbook in the
sense that okay do this now measure this
knowledge that not measure that now
measure that okay write it all in your
report so that's sort of like lecturing
just by saying now copy this down I'll
copy that down I'll copy that down so if
you get away from that in lecturing and
that in practical then you get to the
similarities between the two and you can
apply pretty much every lesson from here
okay the distillation of oh yeah many of
you pointed this out the distillation of
examples in the principles that we did
so we looked at Walter Lewin's lecture
number 10 and then we distilled from our
discussion various principles of
lecturing and performing and many of you
said oh yeah that should have gone
longer they like you like the principles
but we should have done that for longer
which i think is a great sign I think
it's good that you guys are figuring out
what could be improved and I agree with
you I just got so carried away with all
the interesting things you were finding
that I didn't allocate enough time for
the principles
in my next life but I agree but it is
but also the point is that the
principles everyone did appreciate
having principles so that's something to
transfer for your own teaching okay
let's see what kind of interactive
examples and demos can you do for a math
class that was so I brought an example
so this was actually an example I did
last week in my approximation class and
it was I enjoyed it so much I thought
I'd show it to you too so the the
problem we were trying to work out is
well the principle I was teaching was
the principle of easy cases or also
known as extreme cases often but I like
this name better alright and then I
wanted to show that this principle
applies across all kinds of areas you
can use it at math if you do the physics
you can use in engineering and what we
were trying to derive is the volume of a
pyramid
the original problem with this so you
take a pyramid with a square base and
then you lop off some piece at the top
so the pyramid is B by B on the base and
a by a square on the top and it has
height H so what's the volume of that
thing well you can guess a lot of it
from easy cases and at some point so I
won't go through all of that but at some
point you need to work out in part of
this guess they use easy cases you use
the easy case that a equals 0 in other
words you just have a regular square
pyramid you know like one of the
Egyptian pyramids of Gaza visa fees that
may be all right so then what's the
volume
okay well it volume is gonna be
proportional to the height and then it's
got to have some two more lengths here
so it's gotta have to be squared here
there's no a left but then what goes
here
what's the constant well this is
actually where you can use yet again use
easy cases so if you could find a
special pyramid that could be combined
into a shape whose volume you know then
you could actually figure out this
constant alright cuz we don't know the
volume of one pyramid but if you could
replicate it and then assemble them into
a nice shape you're home free okay what
nice shape could you make this into and
what pyramid shape do you need to be
able to do that so take a minute and
think about that okay so anyone have an
idea what shape would you like to make
yeah okay so you want to make a cube
okay so let's talk about how you're
gonna make this cube you'd like to make
the cube and now what piece is that what
part of the pyramid is going to become a
face of the cube well if you have a
square base right so it seems reasonable
to expect that each pyramids can provide
one face of the cube okay so you need
six pyramids to make this cube well what
shape should the pyramid have so that
you can fit them into a queue
how about that she so what's special
about that sheet well see I'll put one
here here's another one on there there's
another one
okay so here we go here's a cube with
six of those pyramids so what's special
about the shape of the pyramid what do
you have to set in it yeah okay the
height is half the base how do you know
that right so the tips touch like this
and this width has to equal the either
side of the square okay so that means if
let's say if H equals one and B equals
to six times the volume is equal to the
volume of the cube which is eight so the
volume of one pyramid is eight sixth or
4/3 so H times B squared is four so you
have to divide it by three and you're
home free okay so there's an example of
a demonstration in that class that you
can use until now the point of it is
that it makes well I mean it's possible
to imagine in your head but it is
actually useful to see these things
built into a cube so even in math class
you can do demonstrations
ooh what's my blackboard philosophy I
write big and sometimes place things
fairly randomly is there a specific
reason for this but I like what you
write down all right so yeah my
blackboard philosophy is not ideal
because of exactly that I do write I
write large which is good but I do place
things kind of randomly sometimes and
that's not ideal so I try to improve
that you know I don't necessarily have a
reason for that but don't necessarily
copy that part of my blackboard style
but it's good that you're observing that
and trying to criticize it okay see how
to practice blackboard work because
we'll talk about that more today but the
basic simplest way that I found is at
the end of your session you just go to
the back of the room and look at the
blackboard and you just see was it
organized did it make sense did I write
a bunch of stuff in between and just
takes a few notes down on that and then
you'll automatically be getting feedback
that you can use to improve your
blackboard work oh yeah several people
suggested that they will point out they
watched a different lecture than Walter
Lewin's lecture 10 because I said oh
watch that one or another one so it
makes here I actually haven't been asked
everyone to watch the same lecture
lecture 10 that's a good suggestion okay
about that oh yeah if you're an
excellent lecture and you are aware of
the common problems you know because
you've taught the course many times
before and you try to address all the
confusing parts can you get away with
not allowing students to ask questions
in class and not asking students
questions than yourself that's a very
interesting question so basically can
you move away from the interactive model
I've been describing and recommending
once you've done it enough and you know
where the students misconceptions are
the answer I thought about that the
answer is really no because you're then
shifting from Talent you're then you're
reverting back to Kelly
now you're telling them things I really
do need to know so instead of telling
them big long song and dance about the
adword machine which they don't really
need to know your toilet telling about
their misconceptions about F equals MA
but the problem is just telling them
that F equals MA not F equals M V
doesn't help them realize that they
really have to have some kind of
cognitive conflict and struggle with it
so questioning is really either them
questioning you questioning them or them
asking questions of you and formulating
questions is really about the only way
to get them to struggle with it so even
then you still have to do it and the
experience you have from teaching at
many times means you'll be doing
questions about useful important
material there's quite an interesting
question so kid
what do I think of group assignments
balancing the advantages of
collaboration with the fact that
individuals each individual may not
encounter all the topics so I generally
don't like them that much I think if you
design a course and you think there's a
coherent set of material everyone really
should try to master that coherent set
of material and not calm off half of it
on one person in the group and the other
person that group so the extreme of this
kind is the graduate seminar where each
graduate student gives a talk on one
topic and then they really learn that
one topic but they don't necessarily
learn the other topics very well all
right so I don't like that very much I
think it's better to allow people to
collaborate but make sure everyone does
their own assignment and yeah
collaborating groups by all means but
please write up your own work as well
what's the use of experiments in Walter
Lewin's lecture was it to show the
predictive power of physics or its
experimental character it's not clear
and in that case wouldn't it be better
if the students perform the experiments
on their own or in a lab class aren't
these demonstrations a waste of time
that can be used to teach more theory
and art shows more appropriate for high
school classes than for physics at MIT
well I think at the time this was 1999
there was no laboratory with the
introductory physics course so this was
the only I need to get my history right
but I'm pretty sure that's right there
was no other way the students would ever
see any application but the other main
point of it is that it showed that the
physics was real now I think it could be
improved as you suggested by Lou and
asking students questions about the
experiments but we're trying to predict
what would happen beforehand for example
but the idea of bringing in objects is
really a sound one I had a teacher at
Caltech he taught the waves course in
the Naumann airwaves course and he said
and he did he always used to bring in a
waveguide which is a to stay basically a
piece of metal in a tube-like shape all
right and he said he always did that
because otherwise the mathematicians
would think it's just a vessel form
because that's how it is and all the
problems you see waveguide you just
start solving Laplace's equation with
all your boundary conditions you get
Bessel functions and waveguide is just
trigger for du Laplace equation get
pestles function has no physical meaning
so he would always bring in the wave
guide so that you knew it was a real
object that you were analyzing and so in
that way blue in using the pendulum
showing that these things actually exist
avoids the trap that many students fall
into which is that symbols just have no
meaning on their own they're just stuff
that goes on on the screen so I think it
is really important that he does that
okay working hard versus smart how do
you respond to people who tell you that
they worked really hard but they still
did poorly okay so that I think
basically the reason is that they didn't
work smart you know so a lot of times so
what do students think working hard
means they generally think it means
reading the book over and over again or
trying really hard to do the problems
but not reflecting so generally they'll
so equivalent in playing chess is
working hard to chest people think oh
that should be playing lots of chess
games but actually that doesn't improve
your chess ability you have to analyze
your chess games reflect on them and
that's what we need to teach students
how to do so whenever they do say that I
say okay well what are you doing let's
look at what you're doing and see if
there ways we can make it more
reflective and less just going through
the same stuff over and over again okay
and then final comment there's some more
questions but I'll leave it there for
now
while watching the 801 walter lewin
lecture I was surprised how much I was
able to find wrong with it even though
he's a great lecture that goes to show
how much we've learned so far in this
class which I thought was a very nice
comment and I'm glad and I hope people
did draw that conclusion from all the
stuff that you found to improve that
lecture means you have actually learned
a lot either in this class or elsewhere
and you could actually make really
excellent lectures really powerful
instructive lectures yourself